hey everyone Merry Christmas
Owen Wilson here yeah I'm gonna read to
you the night before Christmas bundle up
and get ready shouldn't take too long
alright twas the night before Christmas
when all through the house not a
creature was stirring not even a mouse
what why there better not be a mouse in
your house or you've got a problem yeah
anyway
the stockings were hung by the chimney
with care in hopes that Saint Nicholas
soon would be there
well he better watch his head those
stockings might suffocate him they're in
his way the children were nestled all
snug in their beds like me
I'm snug in my bed yeah while visions of
sugarplums danced in their hands
well I dream of sugarplums all right
and mamma in her kerchief and I in my
cap hadn't just nestled our brains for a
long winters nap
probably some farts too when out on the
lawn there arose such a clatter I sprang
from my bed to see what was the matter
away to the window I flew like a flash
tore open the shutters and threw up the
sash the moon on the breast of the
new-fallen snow gave a luster of midday
to objects below those are some big
words there I don't think I understand
nor would a kid to understand that those
need when what to my wondering eyes
should appear but a miniature sleigh and
ten tiny reindeer what so these weren't
real it was just a toy they're tiny
Santa's a big guy he's not tiny with a
little old driver so lively and quick I
knew in a moment it must be st. Nick it
is st. Nick I was confused here more
rapid than Eagles his coursers they came
and he whistled and shouted and called
them by name now Dasher now dancer now
Prancer and vixen on comet on Cupid on
Donner and Blitzen where's it's a rap
song jeans to the top of the porch to
the top of the wall now dash away dash
away dash away all sounds dirty
it sounds very naughty Santa your
grooves I'm a little boy
as dry leaves that before the wild
Hurricane Fly when they meet with an
obstacle mount to the sky so up to the
housetop the coursers they flew with the
sleigh full of toys and st. Nicholas -
yeah and then in a twinkling I heard on
the roof the Prancing and pawing of each
little hoof
that's the hooves I don't know as I drew
in my head and was turning around down
the chimney st. Nicholas came with a
bound
whatsit bound again a really big word I
don't know he was dressed all in fur
from his head to his foot it's probably
really sweaty especially in a chimney
and his clothes were all tarnished with
ashes and soot a bundle of toys he had
flung on his back and he looked like a
peddler just opening his pack all right
his eyes how they twinkled his dimples
how merry his cheeks were like roses his
nose like a cherry
like Mari my nose looks like a smashed
up cherry his droll little mouth was
drawn up like a bow and the beard on his
chin was as white as the snow the stump
of a pipe he held tight in his teeth and
the smoke it encircled his head like a
wreath cool he had a broad face and a
little round belly that shook when he
laughed like a bowl full of jelly
I love generally it's one of my favorite
desserts it was chubby and plump a right
old jolly elf and I laughed when I saw
him in spite of myself a wink of his eye
and a twist of his head soon soon gave
me to know I had nothing dread I was
getting all my presents good he spoke
not a word but went straight to his work
and filled all the stockings then turned
with a jerk
careful Santa
and laying his finger aside of his nose
and giving a nod up the chimney he rose
he sprang to his sleigh to his team gave
a whistle and away they all flew like
the down of a thistle what's up this
hole I don't sounds sounds a dream but I
heard him exclaim ere he drove out of
sight merry Christmas to all and to all
a good night good night everyone Merry
Christmas
Walt Owen Wilson